we are asked what is the volume of this
box and they tell us that each cube is a
cubic foot so just as a reminder a
volume is a measure of how much space
does something take up it's usually
measured in cubic units
and here we're talking about cubic feet
and when they say that each cube is a
cubic foot they're saying that each of
these little boxes each of these cubes
here is exactly a one foot by one foot
by one foot cube we're in three
dimensions night now and we're talking
about three dimensions 3d you literally
need three dimensions you need how tall
you are how wide you are and how deep
you are and for a cubic foot each of
those dimensions is one so each of these
are one cubic foot the entire shape has
one two three four five six cubic feet
in it so the volume of this entire box
is six cubic feet and you see right here
the units has feet and it has a
superscript here of 3 this is feet to
the third power you could use this as
feet times feet times feet or cubic feet
so this is six cubic feet let's do a few
more of these what is the volume of this
shape so this one is this one is quite
quite interesting right over here you
have let's see let's see if we can count
these so you have one two three four
five six seven eight eight unit boxes or
I guess these are cubic inches for this
example so let me so we have eight cubic
inches this is a lot of fun especially
when we get to rotate it so here each
cube is a cubic foot again so we have
one two three cubic feet three cubic
feet let's do one more of these I like
the ones that have these kind of crazy
shapes that we have to rotate to be able
to see all the boxes so each of these is
a cubic meter which means that in each
dimension each of these boxes is one by
one by one meter but how many boxes are
there well see we have one we have one
let me just get a view where I can look
at it better we have one two three four
five six boxes so the total volume here
is six cubic meters
you